hello reject nation I'm Greg outlet I'm
John Humphrey hi so today we're gonna
watch the official trailer for disaster
artist based off of the behind the
scenes of the room
John has seen the room I have not seen
the room I've seen the room
I've shook the man's hand yeah what I'm
good at doing is watching the movies I
need to before a movie comes out I'm
great at that like we're watching a
mother this weekend so I saw Rosemary's
Baby this week I'm good at that so
before the disaster artist comes out I'm
planning on watching the room like a few
days before you know at the same time
though this shouldn't just only be for
people who've seen the room this has to
appeal to a bigger market I'm that guy
and then there's the audience for people
like John who have seen the room yeah
boom oh look at that the video is more
worth it now it's okay when you watch
I'll just sit behind you and throw
spoons alright and today's picture the
day shots gonna go out to Andrew and I
yes hey love you buddy
let's watch this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I really want it to be whatever date is
where this movie the more I see of this
movie the more magical it looks because
it like it really does look like all the
stuff you know and remember from the
movie which is just exciting to see them
recreate some more I see if his Tommy
wise though the more I'm like I gotta
see now this whole thing plan but also
you know the the weird behind the scenes
tale because I haven't read the book so
that stuff is actually like really
intriguing to me I think from my
perspective as a guy who hasn't seen the
room and has only heard plenty of things
about it and I've heard like the quotes
which I mean a partly so highmarket all
that stuff in terms of like seeing the
first trailer to this trailer the first
trailer makes it look like oh it's a
straight-up comedy with the strengths of
like Seth Rogen and James Franco what
they're familiar with this looks more
like a 24 yeah this looks like an a 24
film man gonna be some comedy but it's
also gonna be some trouble - yeah it
looks like a dramedy now as opposed to
the first teaser trailer made to look
like a straight-up comedy this has a
little bit of that hypnotic vibe to it
and what I also liked about it too was
you know I've seen clips of the room and
I've seen how terrible the acting is in
a film and what I find fascinating is
when you see this in-between them doing
takes is like beyond the recreations
when you're just seeing scenes a
dialogue them sitting down at the
than talking and you're like well you
know like it's a good to believable when
he saw he's not just doing the he's not
just doing an imitation where even when
he's off camera in the movie he's like
doing a James Franco's not doing a bad
job he's giving up a sincere performance
as well as dave Franco you know yeah I
mean Tommy Wiseau is such a strange cat
he talks so strangely so yeah it's like
easy for in the shorter clips we saw
before this you know the thing maybe it
is just a weird impression there's so
much of him doing that in this trail
that I'm like yeah for a while it does
start to sound like him and I feel like
they changed his face some because he
does start tall very good yeah but
totally yeah yeah we made up yeah that's
like there's no Zino's yeah I'm really
excited to see how this comes together
and I like that they're going or at
least it appears as though they're going
for that kind of weird dramatic comedic
character so anything cuz that's
everything I know about the room kind of
supports that idea that it was this
weird troubled kind of goofy but also
like you know labor of love so I I'm
really excited and I think in terms of
just an audience perspective dave Franco
as Greg Sestero
and he's all made up yes he's not
completely made up at his hairs dyed in
style Stern away Tommy Wiseau with James
Franco and all his makeup and hair it
makes it easier to believe that they're
not brothers yeah they're both thus the
main stars of this movie it's very
apparent that James Franco is the main
star and that dave Franco is the main
supporting actor yeah so seeing both of
them together in a movie like this when
they both get a shine it's a cool one of
those cool their eyes are like an Owen
Wilson and Luke Wilson did bottle rocket
and were you
her brothers and then you're watching
this and you're like it's gonna be cool
for both of these guys to shine in a
movie together yeah something definitely
struck me to watching them you know I
just thought it was cool like ah they're
gonna leave this movie together
yeah and play these dudes who they're
not riding off of the Franco brother
thing it's like yes doing performances
yeah like it seems like the point is
they're both immersing into these guys
who are already characters in and of
themselves you know who so many people
know from real life and and yeah like I
think that is really cool to see them
both play off each other cuz those guys
seem to clearly have a very close
dynamic even if it's not always easy and
Seth Rogen's seems I don't know his
character but he seems like the guy
who's who's there mainly for us yeah
like the guy who's gonna say all the
things that we would think what we're
watching the room I'm not mistaken I
think he's supposed to be the guy who
can't he's one guy who may have claimed
he's be basically directed because
Tommy's on-screen Mo's you have time so
like the somebody had to sit in and you
know make sure everything was going to I
think that's who he is and I and I love
this Seth Rogen gets to that role it's
like I think the casting of everybody is
really cool in this it looks like it's
gonna be fascinating and gripping
whether or not you've seen the movie
first or whether that inspires you to go
out and watch because that's that's what
I'm saying it's like from my perspective
I'm really drawn to the movie you know I
want to see the movie pretty bad
actually yeah it only makes me want to
watch the room even more I'm kind of
wondering if we should do a review like
that like you've seen the room a week
and we and I have and then we watch it I
could watch the room after this would be
like the first time where it's like yeah
I watched it before Hannah that you
wanted yeah so I'm wondering if like
maybe we should try that out you know
anywho
before we wrap this video up Paige from
the day shut up for Andrew hey Andrew
hey Andrew Hayes is a beautiful young
man from New Jersey
he actually he's been part of a patreon
for a while and he was telling us how he
started up a channel so as a
kind-hearted soul of a gentleman I am I
watched the video he uploaded and
there's a review of a hit show called
Riverdale Riverdale based on the Archie
comic I haven't seen Riverdale iPads on
Netflix like I want to watch it we just
got a RIF account so we might start
watching
Dale and I saw his review I got to tell
you man like genuinely impressed with
your review I know I mentioned this to
you and a Google hangout but I wanted to
say here on camera you got a great
on-camera personality you really got
strong concise thoughts why the
production quality you're just starting
up a channel might not be at its best
that you want it to be at right now keep
going man oh yes I'm never fine
seriously what matters most is you and
your personality and your opinions
genuinely made me go I gotta watch this
show because I am I haven't watched
anyone's review who river Taylor the
only one I've seen like a Rotten
Tomatoes consensus and I've heard
friends be like you gotta watch River
dude but it was your review that made me
go I actually want to check you the show
outta things other than excitement go
check out his channel Dave's Andrew
Hayes I'll put a whole lake at the top
comment of this video for you buddy
Andrew Hayes think the Hays Code the
Hayes kill of movies and a mother rules
pass well guys thanks for tuning in you
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bailed etch on
Humphrey on Twitter and instance and you
can also check out a picture I've become
a picture on a jet today pipe oh yeah
you could be one of these shoutouts yeah